hello welcome to this video against
making no sense the scheme I'm going for
the group failed again being in a dicey
mode come on ok you can go g3 or
whatever I can so we get the Greenfeld
yeah this one a ninety four star the
standard move yeah here I think c5 is in
move can you also take I guess you can
write huh it's be fiber move here or is
that bad I also have this let's try now
chief I however might be an option here
95 Bishop p5e for those kind of ideas
even though that looks a little bit
funny with the bishop being unknown on
h4 okay here text b7 interesting
I wonder well you can just probably give
the pawn 25 is also look that is kind of
interesting okay I'm kind of intrigued
by that you for Queen a five
yeah I probably will play some 92 next
just just aiming for normal compensation
let's same yeah one issue is that if I
castle I'm just giving away is 7 and
this is not really that great c5 there
is a form that doesn't make any sense
hmm not so great actually not quite sure
how I should play this to be honest like
my position that much Queen before I'll
go see five I will probably play c5 no
matter what okay I think I'm happy if he
takes Queen Queen takes should be ok
night eggs also night x also should be
ok though mmm not cool not clear not
clear or let's see what happens if it
also just takes you for nope
okay so he attacks the sea for porn yeah
but still this is not threatening that
much right I can do this
Wow
maybeee for him if I take it rookie 1
i'm getting killed on his seven before I
can go and I can go back to d6 or even
see six
and he has to do something sharp now
otherwise I'll go see form and just just
keep everything here
oh really yeah even have be five year in
this position be five okay I cannot take
that sets km but I think I can do this
this is double porn it's not such a big
issue for more than one reason I think
first of all I can cover with Knight b6
you know now I can come up with Knight
b6 if he attacks it with 92 I mean after
takes takes 90 296 i have e 5 coming
what is he doing we can go clean before
maybe
yeah but is it that great I mean I can
go Bishop f6 on one Knight f6
and I go for the bishop this is this
will be difficult to figure out anyway
with one minute on the clock yeah clean
here queen bee seven rupee eight or just
Quincy seven okay let's go here it's the
most active continuation so p8 to get
the Queen oh let's not to move that I
reckoned I'd I that I saw interesting hi
I'm listening I defy for what taking the
pawn here I can just take it should be
good now I'm attacking c3 here what is
the dealio rupee 10 I have this is C
porn is until um isn't to be
underestimated rugby 7s God rupee seven
coming up
you
still very tricky let's do this I cannot
calculate yeah this is difficult
difficult to figure out completely check
okay so it should be good now check
check check check check check check
check check mate ok so poo tough game
tough game and yeah the opening yeah was
played with some kind of yeah I knew I
think this is a line now let's let's put
it that way taking hear it think
normally white goes to need for him yeah
he also be five as a move but okay I was
just experimenting him I have some
doubts that this is great to be honest
for black yeah here I was reasonably
sure that I should be okay and not be in
any any big trouble also now it's very
tough you can go see for I can go efore
this I thought was very surprising that
he allows me to support this pawn the
computer I'll just wants to castle which
is quite sensible I don't think this is
particularly bad no yeah I'm clearly
better ed5 probably was wrong the engine
wants to take play this and it says this
is equal typical got a completely wacky
line and the engine assessment is equal
yeah probably this is what you should do
I'm in here this is not making her this
is not looking great Bishop takes edge
for even though is better though then my
move quassia I could have sent the night
on the on the edge of the board now I'm
clearly better with with the dual idea
here yeah not clearly bad ads minus two
blacks completely willing that was
better than my continuation even though
this is also leading to an advantage
King the a tangent move Wow but this
isn't so bad right yeah it's also
winning check he just has to yeah he
fights this protected pass only through
only three check there is no way out
there check check there is no way out
now he probably had to improve um here
somewhere round here when when c4 is the
probably right not allowing me to
support the d3 porn
something like this and then back yeah
probably equal ish this pollution ok I
want an interesting game though thanks
for watching